الى لبنان حيث افاد الدفاع المدني في جنوب
البلاد باستشهاد شخص واصابه اثنين في قصف
بمسيره اسرائيليه لسياره في بلده خربه سلم
اثناء التشيع القيادي في حزب الله وسام
طويل وقال حزب الله ان ثلاثه من مقاتليه
استشهدوا في غاره اسرائيليه في بلده
الغندوري واعلن الحزب عن مهاجمته بمسيرات
ملغمه مقر قياده المنطقه الشماليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في ب مدينه صفد وقال الحزب ان
العمليه تاتي ردا على اغتيال وسام طويل
والقائد في حماس صالح العاروري كما اعلن
الحزب عن استهدافه ثكنه فتاح وتجمع للجنود
قرب ثكنه ادمي ومواقع الملكي والبغدادي
وحنيته ورويس القرن وقصفت طائرات ومسيرات
ومدفعيه اسرائيليه محيطه عده بلدات في
جنوب لبنان بينما قالت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه انه تم تصفيه مسؤول وحده
المسيرات في حزب حزب الله في قصف اسرائيلي
داخل الجنوب
اللبناني لمتابعه التطورات ينضم الينا من
بلده رميش جنوب لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره
مازن ابراهيم ومن الجليل الاعلى مراسله
الجزيره جيفاره البديري اهلا بكم ابدا معك
مازن وجديد التطورات خاصه مع انتهاء تشييع
وسام
طويل نعم في الواقع غنوى الغارات والقصف
الاسرائيلي مستمر على اكثر من منطقه قبل
قليل كان هنالك استهداف من قبل الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه لمنطقه الغندوري
مجددا وهي المنطقه والبلده التي كانت قد
اغارت عليها المسيرات الاسرائيليه صباحا
واستهدفت احدى السيارات هذا الامر تكرر في
اكثر من منطقه في اكثر من موقع عمليات قصف
مستمر من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
الغارات المقاتلات الحربيه نف ت على طول
الخط الحدودي مجموعه كبيره من
الاستهدافات لهذه المناطق في المقابل حزب
الله كان قد اعلن عن تنفيذ مجموعه ايضا من
العمليات نتحدث عن ثماني عمليات تم
تنفيذها ولكن ابرز تلك العمليات هي اطلاق
المسيرات الهجوميه وفق بيان صادر عن الحزب
باتجاه مقر قياده المنطقه الشماليه في
القوات البريه
الاسرائيليه هذه العمليه التي وضعها حزب
الله في اطار الرد على اغتيال القيادي في
حركه حماس صالح العاروري واغتيال القائد
الميداني في حزب الله وسام طويل اعتبر
بانها تاتي ردا على هذه الاغتيالات التي
باتت تتكرر على مستوى العمق اللبناني من
خلال الاستهدافات المتعدده بالمسيرات
وبالطاقة
ما تم اطلاق الصواريخ وايضا خلال عمليه
تشييع القائد الميداني والعسكري في حزب
الله وسام الطويل في بلده خربه سلم تم
ايضا
استهداف المنطقه والمربع الذي تجري في
عمليه التشييع نحن نتحدث عن نحو كيلومتر
واحد يفصل المنطقه التي يجري فيها التشييع
عن المكان الذي تم استهدافه من قبل احدى
المسيرات اطلقت صاروخين في بدايه الامر
باتجاه سياره واعقب ذلك بصاروخ ثالث مما
وفق الدفاع المدني الى استشهاد شخص واصابه
شخصين بجراح وهذا ما دفع حزب الله قبل
قليل الى نعي احد مقاتليه وقال انه قضى في
خربه سلم جراء هذا الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
من خلال الطائرات المسيره لتلك المنطقه
شكرا لك مازن انتقل الان الى جفارا ونتابع
معك اخر التطورات من الجبهه الشماليه
المحاذيه للحدود
اللبنانيه في اقل من سبع ساعات غنوه دوت
صافرات الانذار على طول الحدود 15 مره وال
الصافرات كانت على طول خط الشريط الحدودي
في القطاعات الاوسط والشرقي وا الغربي
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال بان المسيره المفخخه
التي تجاوزت الحدود ووصلت الى قاعده قياده
مقر
القياده العسكريه للجيش الاس الشماليه عند
مدينه صفد لم تؤدي الى اضرار او وقوع
اصابات وا انه تم تدميرها وانها سقطت وفق
الجيش الاسرائيلي في منطقه بعيده نوعا ما
او قليلا حتى عن مقر القياده ولكن ينظر
باهميه كبيره الى ما تصفه بهذا التطور بان
المسيرات اصبحت الان هي سلاح جديد لدى حزب
الله يستخدمه في داخل داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه ولكن بالطبع ايضا هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه ونخلا عن مسؤولين عسكريين
اسرائيليين قالوا انه تم اليوم استهداف
مسؤول المسيرات في داخل حزب الله في
الجنوب اللبناني من خلال قصف وانه بهذه
العمليه الجديده اي بعد حسن الطويل وايضا
الشيخ صالح العاروري ياتي هذا الاستهداف
مما سيضعف حسب راي المسؤولين العسكريين
الاسرائيليين قدره حزب الله على الاستمرار
في توجيه المسيرات خاصه المسيرات ال يعني
التي يتم تفخيخها ولكن في ذات الوقت الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بيان محدث صدر قبل قليل قال
بانه تم اليوم استهداف مواقع عده في داخل
الجنوب اللبناني تحديدا في منطقتي كفار
كلا وارون ردا على مواقع اطلاق النار وع
على ما يبدو ايضا اطلاق المسيرات والقذائف
فيما ذكرت صحيفه ها ارت الاسرائيليه نقلا
عن احداثيات جديده بان ال استخدام حزب
الله للصواريخ المضاده للدروع هو
الاعلى منذ اي حرب مضت وعلى اي جبهه على
المستوى الاسرائيلي ان لم يكن ايضا على
المستوى الدولي ولكن بالطبع ايضا الوضع
السياسي ينظر اليه هنا ب اهميه كبيره اي
نتائج الزياره التي يقوم بها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن لانه
واضح حتس ب وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه خبر
الجبهه الشماليه هو صف اصبح الان الخبر
الاول في كل النشرات الاخباريه حتى قبل
الوضع في غزه وقبل الوضع السياسي فبالتالي
ينظر بعد احداث اليوم وتسلسلها على انه
الخبر الاهم وبالتالي ينظر ايضا ل زياره
بلينكن وما سيتمكن من خلاله من ايجاد حل
سياسي على الارض على هذه شكرا لك جفاره
المديري